اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء من اين ياتي
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه
بالمقاتلين خلافا لما قد يتبادر الى
الاذهان فانه لا يجند بالضروره من داخل
الاوساط المتدينه على العكس من ذلك تبدو
تجربه التنظيم في مجال التجنيد في اوروبا
مناقضه كليا لما هو سائد انه يختار
مقاتليه ممن تقودهم الجرائم والمخدرات الى
السجون وتجربه تنظيم الدوله في بلجيكا كما
كشف عنها برنامج الجزيره التحقيقي ما خف
اعظم تعطي انطباعا اقرب الى الواقع بان
اوروبا الغربيه كلها غدت خزانا يمد هذا
التنظيم
بالمقاتلين بالتوازي مع مع غض السلطات
هناك الطرف عن المجندين والمرشحين للتجنيد
محاوله للفهم في تقرير نسيبه موسى وما
يليه من
نقاش الذئاب المنفرده رعب تنظيم الدوله
الذي هز عروش اجهزه الامن الاوروبيه من
عاصمه الاتحاد الاوروبي الى ارض الخلافه
رحله محفوفه بالغموض يخوضها مئات الشباب
كواليس هذا الطريق منذ بدايته وصولا الى
نهايته المجهوله تتبعها ما خفي
اعظم بعد هذه الليله تحديدا الث من نوفمبر
2015 اتجهت انظار اجهزه المخابرات
الاوروبيه صوب العاصمه البلجيكيه ذلك ان
من وصفوا بالعقول المدبره ومن ضربوا
باحزمة يجند تنظيم الدوله مقاتليه هو طرف
الخيط الذي وجد في بروكسل وكشف قليلا من
غموضه مقاتل من العائدين من صفوف التنظيم
في سوريا اذ يتضح ان التنظيم وظف جيدا
الجرائم التي ترتكب في سوريا كي يستدر عطف
من يتطلع لتجنيدهم ومن ثم ينتقل الى اللعب
على وتر ضياع الهويه الذي تستشعره شريحه
كبيره من ابناء المهاجرين العرب
والمسلمين وفق شهادات ووثائق اوردها
الفيلم يتضح ان تنظيم الدوله يجد في
السجون البلجيكيه بيئه خصبه للتجنيد
وتحديدا في اوساط السجناء الجنائيين ذلك
ان سلطات السجون البلجيكيه لا تفصل
المتهمين في قضايا ارهاب عن نزلاء القضايا
الجنائيه نسبه لا باس بها من مقاتلي
التنظيم لديهم تاريخ اجرامي دخلوا السجن
مجرمين وخرجوا منه جهاديين مجندين فالشق
قان صلاح وابراهيم عبد السلام منفذا هجمات
باريس التي استهدفت مواقع منها مسرح
الباتك كان من اصحاب السوابق وقد اغلقت
الشرطه البلجيكيه حانت هما بتهمه ترويج
المخدرات قبل ثمانيه ايام فقط من تنفيذ
الهجمات الداميه والمثير للحيره فيما
تناولته وثائق الفيلم ان تنظيم الدوله كان
على علم مسبق بتاريخ مجنيه بكامل تفاصيله
فقد اظهرت وثائق مصربه من الاداره العامه
للحدود داخل التنظيم هذه المعلومه بشكل لا
يقبل الشك بل واكدت ان بلجيكا هي بالفعل
البلد الاوروبي الاول في تصدير المقاتلين
الاجانب قياسا الى عدد السكان بواقع
614 مقاتلا ما بين 2013
و204 بالاستناد الى شهادات عائلات شباب
عبر الحدود للقتال مع تنظيم الدوله
ومعلومات رجال مخابرات يتكشف دور غامض
للامن البلجيكي فالشرط البلجيكيه كانت
تمتلك المعلومه الدقيقه عن مكان اختباء
صلاح عبد السلام احد منفذي هجمات باريس
ولم تقدم على اعتقاله الا بعد 100 يوم
بضغط من السلطات الفرنسيه وفي مسيره تجنيد
مقاتلي تنظيم الدوله توجه عائلات المجندين
الاتهام للشرطه البلجيكيه بغض الطرف عن
رحيل ابنائها صوب ما توصف بارض الخلافه
دون ان تحرك ساكنا لمنعهم ويقول خبراء
امنيون ان السلطات في بروكسل اتبعت هذا
النهج للتخلص من المقاتلين واملا في الا
يعودوا الى
بلجيكا ينضم الينا من عمان الخبير في شؤون
الجامعات الاسلاميه حسن ابو هنيه ومن
باريس الخبيره في الشؤون الامنيه ومكافحه
الارهاب ان جيوشي لكننا نبدا مع الزميل
تامر المسحال مقدم برنامج الجزيره
التحقيقي مع خفيه اعظم معي هنا في
الاستوديو تامر مرحبا بك هذه المعلومات
التي توصلت اليها او الحقائق في الحقيقه
مساله
تجنيد المجرمين او اصحاب السوابق من الس
سجون بهذه البساطه ليصبحوا مقاتلين في
صفوف تنظيم الدوله او ذئاب منفرده تمرح في
المجتمعات الغربيه في انتظار
لحظه او سعه الصفر هذه المعلومات هل هي
غائبه عن السلطات في تلك البلدان مثلا هذه
كانت علامه استفهام كبيره طرحها هذا
التحقيق محمود نحن عملنا على هذا التحقيق
منذ اشهر وفي اطار البحث قابلنا اكثر من
100 شخصيه في بلجيكا وايضا في دول اوروبيه
لنستقي ونبحث ونعد هذا الموضوع موضوع شائك
ومعقد وك كان
من الاشياء المعقده هو الوصول الى ايجابات
لكثير من علامات الاستفهام علامات
الاستفهام لدى المواطن العادي في اوروبا
لدى كثير من الاوساط تحديدا اوساط
المهاجرين وكثير من علامات الاستفهام على
طرق تجنيد تنظيم الدوله لعناصره في اوروبا
تم التركيز على بروكسل لان البروكسل هي
الاكثر تصديرا للمقاتلين مقارنه بعدد
سكانها اذا قارنا العدد بالمقاتلين من دول
اوروبا المختلفه لافت محمود ان السلطات
الامنيه ونحن حاولنا على مدار اشهر ان
نلتقي باكثر من مسؤول امني في داخل بلجيكا
كان هناك امتناع عن الحديث حاولنا مع وزير
الداخليه وعدد من اقطاب الاجهزه الامنيه
وحتى حاولنا عن طريق برلمان بروكسل هل من
رد على هذه الاسئله هل من رد على كثير من
علامات الاستفهام هل من رد على
قضيه الشرطي البلجيكي من اصول مغاربيه عبد
الحميد اد راحي وهذا الرجل الذي ابلغ عن
مكان وجود صلاح عبد السلام ولم يعت قل ل
100 يوم قبل ان تتدخل السلطات الفرنسيه
وتم تجاهل معلومته المعلومه التي تقدم بها
عن مكان وجود صلاح عبد السلام والذي كان
بالقرب من احد مقرات الاجهزه الامنيه
التابعه للسلطات البلجيكيه في العاص في حي
مولم بيك واضح انه هناك كان تساؤل عن هذا
الامر وايضا المستفيد الاكبر اليمين
المتطرف الذي كان منفتحا علينا في الحديث
ومنفتح على كل وسائل الاعلام سيده انجيو
ديشلي هل ناخذ هذه المعلومات على انها رخا
امنيه تراخي من قبل السلطات ام نسيء الظن
فيما يجري برمته ونقول ان هناك اطرافا
مستفيده من صعود تنظيم الدوله او صعود هذه
الفزاعه في المجتمعات الاوروبيه لاغراض
يعرفها اليمين واليسار على السواء في
الحقيقه زميلك عامل بشكل خاص على
بلجيكا صحيح اننا اليوم هناك م الى ان
نظهر بلجيكا على انها الحلقه
الاضعف في الوضع في اوروبا بالنسبه لهذا
الناحيه
الامنيه اعتقد ان
ما يدل عليه هذا هذا التقرير هو صحيح في
بلدان اوروبيه اخرى
منذ اكثر من 15 او 20 سنه نعرف ان هناك
انتداب و
التطرف بين الشباب وهو وضع
معروف من قبل جميع المسؤولين الاوروبيين
في
بلدانهم وهي حركيه او ديناميكيه موجوده من
منذ وقت طويل ولم يتم القيام باي
شيء
للتعامل مع هذا الامر معدا
والتطرف في
الاوساط
الاجرام هذه هي النقطه الاولى النقطه
الثانيه هو انه منذ 20 سنه
ايضا
انظمه
الاحياء
الشعبيه بما في ذلك في انجلترا حيث
هناك
نظام اجتماعي مفروض ان يمنع مثل هذه
الظاهره
هناك تهميش للشباب وخاصه
المسلمين و
يتم تكوين عالم منفصل عن الواقع وعن
بالمقاطعه سيده ان عذرا عذرا على المقاطعه
سيده ان ما دمت قد عدت بالزمن الى 20 سنه
الى الوراء كانت هناك انتخابات في فرنسا
قبل 20 عاما وحل فيها ثانيا على غير ما هو
ومتوقع السيد جان ماري لوبان زعيم الجبهه
الوطنيه باقواله المتطرفه وادبه الموغل في
التشدد تجاه المسلمين وتجاه المهاجرين وعد
ذلك في ذلك الوقت زلزالا هز فرنسا فتجمع
الفرنسيون ولقن هذا الرجل درسا واعتبروه
مهرجا وصل الى هذه المكانه واعاد مع جاك
شيراك في الانتخابات بمحض الصدفه البحته
الان اصبح هذه اصبحت هذه المقولات مقبوله
للغايه في اوروبا اصبحت وا اصبح الجبهه
الوطنيه وزعمائها اصبحوا من اللاعبين
الاساسيين في الانتخابات في فرنسا كيف حدث
هذا يعني بالنظر الى انهم هم المستفيدون
من ظاهره صعود تنظيم الدوله على هذا
النحو في الحقيقه ما يمكن ان
اقوله هو ان هناك حركيه مسؤوله عن
سواء المتطرف الذي
يستخدم هذه
النواحي الخوف من الاسلام
والتطرف
[موسيقى]
وهذا هو
عمل يقوم عليه اليمين
المتطرف في الوقت نفسه هناك احزاب
يمينيه غير اليمين الم طرف ومن اليسار
ايضا
الاثنان ساهم في ان يتطور
الوضع الى
[موسيقى]
تهميش تجمعات تعيش على هامش
المجتمع
وتطور وهذه هي مسؤوليه السياسيين منذ 20
عاما سواء في بلجيكا طيب دعيني دعيني
اتحول الى الى السيد حسن ابو هنيه ضيفنا
من الاردن لعلنا نفهم اكثر مساله قدره
تنظيم الدوله على تجنيد هؤلاء كيف يتحول
المرء سيد حسن من تاجر مخدرات مرموق كصلاح
عبد السلام واخيه الكل في المجتمع
يعرفونهم ويعرفون حنتهم المشهوره ببيع
المخدرات كيف يتحول الى جهادي وطالب
للاستشهاد ومستعد للتضحيه بنفسه في عمليات
من هذا النوع في غضون ايام قليله يتم
تجنيده بهذه الصوره كيف يحدث هذا
الامر لا شك بان هذه الظاهره ربما لم نكن
نعرفها على الاطلاق سابقا انما هي في مع
الجيل الجديد مع جيل جهاديه ومقاتلي تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه في حاله القاعده سابقا
مع الاجيال السابقه كانت هناك تتم عمليات
تكوين وتنشئه طويله نوع من التلقين
الايديولوجي والانتماء الى شبكات قرابه
وصداقه وعمليه تلقين بعيده وطويله المدى
قد تستغرق سنوات ولكن الان نشاهد بان هناك
عمليات تحول نحو الراديكاليه السريعه بشكل
سريع جدا كما اوضحت هو في حاله صلاح
وابراهيم عبد السلام او صلاح او الاخوين
الذين نفذ هجمات بروكسي للاخوين بكراوي
خالد وابراهيم كانت لهم خلفيات جنائيه
ويدخلوا السجن ثم بعد ذلك يتحولوا بسرعه
اعتقد ان المدخل الاساسي في هذا السياق هو
مدخل الاهو هويه لانه نشاهد انه هناك فعلا
اذا قرانا الحاله البلجيكيه فعلا كاكبر
مشاركه للمقاتلين الاجانب في الخارج قياسا
لعدد السكان ثم بعد ذلك بالتاكيد تاتي
فرنسا في مشاركه ايضا من احد اكبر
المشاركات سوف نجد ان موضوع عمليات الهويه
والاندماج حاسمه في هذا ال في هذا المجال
وكما قالت الزميله من باريس هذا الامر
واضح هناك عمليات اقصاء وتهميش ليس فقط
على الصعيد الاقتصادي كما هو الحال في
مولينبيك وكذلك في بلجيكا في بروكسل وكذلك
في سان اندوني في الضواحي الباريسيه هناك
رابط اساسي وهو رابط عمليات نزع الهويه
وبالتالي السياسات شاهدنا بروكسل وبلجيكا
عمليات الحجاب
وبالتالي منع الحجاب مثلا ونشوء حركه مثلا
من اجل الشريعه من اجل بلجيكا في 2010
نشاهد انهم جميعهم خرجوا من هذا المكان لا
شك بان هناك مشكله عميقه في الايدولوجيا
الهويات استاذ حسن كل هذا لا يفسر كيف
يمكن ان يتحول المرء من شارب للخمر من
متاجر في المخدرات من صاحب حانه من مجرم
صاحب سوابق الى طالب للاستشهاد طامع في
الجنه وعنده القدره ان ان يضحي بنفسه من
خلال تفجير نفسه في في تجمع هنا او
هناك
لا شك ان هذه معضله في قضيه التحول
السيكولوجي والتحول السوسيولوجي الاجتماعي
بمن شخص فعلا وهذه ليست ظاهره هي ظاهره
ليست في اوروبا حتى في العالم العربي نعلم
ان السجون يعني كما نعلم حاله الزرقاوي او
حاله جهاديين في داخل القاعده او الجماعات
الجهاديه كانت هي نشات فعلا في ظاهره في
السجون من جماعه اعتقد انه هذا يرتبط
بعمليات سيكولوجيه عميقه تنتج عن نوعا ما
ازمات في داخل الهويه الشخصيه قبل ان تكون
على صعيد هويه المجتمع والدوله لكن عندما
تتكامل هذه الازمه الهويات على الصعيد
الشخصي وعلى الصعيد الاجتماعي مع وجود بعض
القضايا العادله هناك نوع من التطهير
اعتقد انه مدخل التطهير النفسي هو المدهل
الاساسي هناك اشخاص يريدوا ان يتطهروا
بطريقه او باخرى وبالتالي يلجوا لعمليه ما
يسم د ا اعد مجددا الى زميلي تامر المسحال
هنا في الاستديو تامر ربما ما لم تبحثو في
الفيلم او ما لم تتطرق اليه هو مساله
التعديل السلوكي اذا يعني اذا سرح بنا
الخيال في نظريات المؤامره ربما نذهب الى
هذا المذهب هذا الامر طرحه الامريكيون
كثيرا في افلامهم افلام العميل بورن فيلم
ستيت اوف بلاي لراسل كرو وبن افلك تحدث عن
تعديل سلوكي يصنع المرء بموجبه اشياء لا
يفعلها في العاده يقتل ولا يعبا بهذا
الامر ينفذ الاوامر بصوره حرفيه هل هناك
مجال ل الذهاب الى هذا المذهب هناك في في
بروكسل كما في العديد من العواصم
الاوروبيه واضح ان هناك مساحه فارغه هذه
المساحه الفارغه لعب فيها تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه وهذا كان واضحا بمعنى ان تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه من الواضح انه لم
يستهدف طرق التجنيد او لم يستخدم طرق
التجنيد المعتاده في الذهاب الى شخصيات
معروفه بالتدين او ما شابه وهذا من خلال
الادله والحقائق التحدي امامنا كان محمود
في هذا التحقيق هو الحقيقه والمهنيه
واعطاء الوثيقه عندما كنا نتحدث عن صلاح
وابراهيم عبد السلام كثير من الاتهامات
قيلت وهناك كثير من الشكوك والاحاديث لكن
ان تاتي بوثيقه من بلديه مولنبيك وهو الحي
الذي يقطن فيه صلاح وابراهيم عبد السلام
وتقول هذه الوثيقه انه تم اغلاق حانته قبل
ثمانيه ايام من هجمات باريس بتهمه ترويج
المخدرات بعد ان تم اعتقالهم وتوقيفهم
سؤال كبير نحن لم نجد كثير من بالتاكيد
هذا الت ثمانيه ايام هل هي كافيه لتحويل
المراه هكذا من من هذه ووج الى ايام تم
اغلاق الحانه وقبلها بثلاثه شهور تم ايقاف
الاخوين بتهمه ترويج المخدرات هنا هذا
سؤال كبير عندما يطرح على العديد من
الاسئله في كثير من من من الاهالي عندما
قالت واحده من امهات اعضاء تنظيم الدوله
انني ذهبت بنفسي الى الاجهزه الامنيه وقلت
لهم ان ابني سوف يذهب الى سوريا والعراق
امنعو قال لا نستطيع ان نمنعه هناك كثير
من التساؤلات ثم اليس اليس غريبا ان كل
المشتبه بهم او كل الذين نفذوا بحسب
الروايات الرسميه في اوروبا كل الذين
نفذوا هذه العمليات قتلوا جميعا باستثناء
صلاح صلاح ابد سلام وحده يعني نحن محمود
كنا امام كثير من التساؤلات ولكن في ذات
الوقت تمكنا من لقاء احد كوادر التنظيم في
بروكسل وعندما طرحنا عليه عدد من الاسئله
كان من بينها ان هؤلاء وجدوا في التنظيم
انه هو الخيار الافضل لهم في ظل ما يمارس
عليهم من اضطهاد وبكل تاكيد نحن اردنا في
هذا التحقيق ان نقدم الصوره بارئها
المختلفه ونحاول ونحاول ان الوصول نقدم
هذه الصوره للمشاهد ليحكم وبالتاكيد سوف
نتابع هذا الامر في ملفات متتابعه سيده
انجيو ديشلي في الفيلم الذي او التحقيق
الاستقصائي الذي قدمه
تامر عباره قالها احد اليمينيين بصراحه
شديده يقول انه لا تعايش بين الاسلام وبين
هذه الهويه المسيحيه الاوروبيه وانه لا
مكان للاسلام ولا للمسلمين في المجتمعات
الاوروبيه هل هذا من قبيل المصادفه ام ان
هناك فعلا مخاوف من انتشار المسلمين
والاسلام في اوروبا على نحو قد يطغى او
يغير الديمغرافيه الموجوده في اوروبا يعني
التقارير او الابحاث تشير باختصار شديد
الى ان فرنسا بعد ع سنوات من الان فقط
سيصبح واحد من كل خمس فرنسيين هو مسلم ان
هولندا في غضون اقل من 15 عاما ستصبح دوله
يغلب على سكانها المسلمون فرنسا لديها اقل
من 40 سنه اذا ظلت معدلات التوالد
والتكاثر الاسلامي من خلال الهجره او من
خلال الميلاد الطبيعي فرنسا ستصبح جمهوريه
اسلاميه في اقل من 40
عاما المشكله ليس هو
الجاليه المسلمه لان في فرنسا من نتحدث عن
فرنسا نحن في مجتمع لائكي
علماني فيه
مجتمعات كثيره او جات كثيره ورسميا
ومنطقيا يتعايشون وكل جاليه تتعامل ولا
تسيطر احداها على
الاخرى المشكله او الجمله التي
ذكرتموها لهذا المسؤول
السياسي ربما
ينتظر او يتوقع انه يريد ان يجعل
مشكله ليست مشكله حقيقيه ان تصبح مشكله
حتى تصبح يصبح ذلك اداه سياسيه
يعني انه عندما يصرح مسؤول سياسي بان
التهديد الاكبر هو الاسلام لان الاسلام لا
يتعارض مع الجمهوريه فانا اود ان اقول لك
لو رايت الاسلاميين يقولون لكم الشيء نفسه
يقولون الاسلام ليس انا اعتذر مجددا عن
المقاطعه سيده ان اعتذر مجددا عن المقاطعه
في ظل هذه الظروف او في ظل هذه المقولات
فانه لو لم يكن هناك تنظيم الدوله لوجب
على اليمينيين او الذين يخشون الاسلام ان
يخترعوا تنظيم الدوله هم يعيشون على هذا
الامر هو بالنس بالنسبه لهم حقيقه عضويه
لابد من وجود تنظيم الدوله حتى يصعد هؤلاء
ويجابه الخطر الذي يتحدث عنه صاحبنا هذا
اليميني
اعتقد ان هذه هي
نظريه
التنافس التي كانت في الولايات
المتحده
بعد اعتداءات 2001 ليس هذا السؤال السؤال
هو المساله هو لم نوجد اطمئنانا في مجمعنا
الاي حت نتفادى
الظواهر الدينيه او المواطنه ان
تصبح طريقه تستخدم للوصول الى الحكم ويتم
استخدامه ايضا لاغراض سياسيه وغيرها اذا
لم
نتمكن من ايجاد هذا الاطمئنان وهذا
الهدوء والاحداث في الشرق الاوسط لها
مفعول
مباشر على الساحه الاوروبيه والمشكله هنا
في المجتمعات الاوروبيه هو انها لا
تفهم السياسيون على الاقل طيب حس حس حسنا
انك اتيت على ذكر الاحداث هنا في الشرق
الاوسط سؤال هنا للسيد حسن ابو هنيه الى
اي مدى اسهم الانكفاء الذي تعرضت له ثورات
الربيع العربي وفشل الاسلاميين المعتدلين
الذين لديهم استعداد للانخراط في العمليه
الديمقرا ولعبه الانتخابات وما الى ذلك
الى اي مدى اسهم اقصائهم بل والتنكيل بهم
في بعض الاحوال مثل ما يحدث في مصر الان
في صعود تنظيم الدوله ورواج مقولاته على
هذا النحو في اوروبا وفي اوساط المسلمين
عامه لا شك ان هذا امر كان حاسما لا يمكن
يعني اذا نظرت الى عام 2011 كان تنظيم
القاعده يتفكك بعد مقتل زعيم التنظيم بن
لادن ودخل حتى التنظيم في عمليات تكيف
ايديولوجي وبالتالي شاهدنا ينخرط حتى
بطرائق او باخرى مجموعه من الحركات حتى في
عمليه اللعبه الديمقراطيه والمشاركه في
الانتخابات بطرائق عديده ولكن عندما تم
التنكيل بالذين وصلوا الى السلطه عن طريق
صندوق الانتخابات ثم اللجوء الى صناديق
الرصاص كما حدث في مصر وفي وفي مناطق
عديده هذا ادى الى تعزيز ايديولوجيا
المتطرفه او تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه بشكل
او باخر وبالتالي شاهدنا هناك تحول كبير
ثم ان هذه الحركات وهذه الدكتاتوريات
واعاده بناء السلطويه التي كانت هي مدعومه
بالتاكيد من الغرب بمعنى لم نشاهد هناك اي
مواقف على الاطلاق رافضه لهذه الانقلابات
بشكل واضح وصريح بل كانت تتمتع بالدعم
والاسناد بشكل واضح ولذلك شاهدنا هناك
تكامل بين هذه القوى الامبرياليه وهذه
الانظمه الدكتاتوريه هي التي ادت الى صعود
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه بشكل واضح وصريح
هذا امر بدا
واضح وكانت كذلك في الغرب شاهدنا ان هناك
نموا لهذا التوجه نعلم ان التقرير
البريطاني وكذلك مشروع القرار الامريكي
باعتبار ان حتى حركه الاخوان المسلمين
التي تم تعريفها من قبل هذه الثورات
المضاده باعتبارها حركه ارهابيه وكذلك في
اوروبا اصبح يتعامل مع هذه الحركات كناقل
ومسيره نحو التطرف هذا ساهم بالتاكيد
بولاده اجيال اكثر قناعه بان لا يوجد هناك
اي ديمقراطيه سوى الديكتاتوريات هذا كان
امر حاسم سواء في العالم العربي او في
الغرب لان الغرب وهذه الانظمه متحالفين
بعدم التحول الى عمليه تحول ديمقراطي
صحيحه شكرا جزيلا لك الاستاذ حسن ابو هنيه
الخبير في شؤون الجماعات الاسلاميه كان
معنا من عمان واشكر ضيفتنا من باريس
الخبيره في الشؤون الامنيه ومكافحه
الارهاب انجيو ديشلي واشكر ضيفنا هنا في
الاستوديو الزميل تامر المسحال مقدم
برنامج ما خفي اعظم وهو برنامج تحقيقي
شكرا جزيلا لكم
ابعاد تعرض سجن في جنوب البحرين لهجوم
مسلح وفرار عشره سجناء هي ما نتابعه في
الملف الثاني مع الحبيب الغريبي